alors on se marre un petit peu plus sur
vous et orlando ont fait faire une hardy
view
[Musique]
alors dos vous pensez à quoi en ce
moment là je suis légèrement déstabilisé
pourquoi le début peut-être parce que
dans la loge de maquillage est arrivé
derrière moi
pleurons il la pousse un cri strident on
ne retient qu'un corbeau
c'était comment le
leur j'étais tellement content de le
voir là bas il est content aussi il m'a
appelé c'est thierry gêné vienne caisse
il ya bafoue la cia pas ma fille j'ai
vraiment cet accent horrible and you
tube à orlando à qui vous auriez aimé
ressembler quand vous étiez petit
orlando d'un brad pitt ce n'était pas
mal mais ton coup j'aurais préféré voilà
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois il avait 403 me revient je pense
que je suis de plus en plus émotif voilà
donc une
chanson une voie qu'elle assiste
aujourd'hui vous qui avez tous connus
quel artiste vous pouvez vous tirer des
larmes hollande aujourd'hui record
d'origine très bien qu
alors vous changeriez quoi on joue là
comme ça aujourd'hui si vous aviez une
baguette magique
d'avoir tout de suite comme sa première
avoir 20 centimètres de plus
quel est le péché qui vous manque le
plus kim est entré plus tu te séduire
des pouvoirs un obtenir la personne que
lui ne voudrais pas c'est à dire 'voilà
ce serait bien d'obtenir un jeu les deux
trois péchés qui rôdent en ce moment là
de temps en temps ou et vous savez plus
fait plusieurs fois dans la journée de
la gare s'évader gars comme on dit
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire orlando
de plus négatif sur vous un truc pour
vous pourrir vraiment la colère et je
suis quelqu'un qui sait quelqu'un
orlando
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus mal en fait je pense que je suis
quelqu'un de feu mais c'est difficile et
ses prétentions de profondément honnête
voilà dix comme tout comme doute de ma
parole ou qu'on conjuguait avec
quelqu'un vous a traité d' escroc un
jour et c'est une chance des malhonnêtes
c'est la chose qui pourrait vraiment
même et blessant très bien leur doux
quand le téléphone sonne est ce que vous
êtes heureux ou agacé est-ce que tu as
personnaliser la sonnerie de portable
est ce que c'est une chanson de ta soeur
quand ça sonne ça fait quoi quand et
comme souvent d'alpha il venait d'avoir
18 ans
orlando
vous feriez quoi s'il veut rester 24
heures à vivre car et de changer de la
vitre eux
[Musique]
je sais pas j'essaierai de de mettre
tout en ordre avant que je parte je suis
quelqu'un de magna je suis maniaque de
l'ordre vendredi à douala et je pense
que je laisserais tout pour que les gens
après que je partis chacun fait ça ça
s'adresse à voilà il y avait ça faire
s'est il y avait ça reste à fait moi et
toi t'es quoi site rester 24 heures à
vivre j'irai tout ranger chez orlando
non
je te pose la question
j'ai déjà répondu ouais je prendrai une
maison à crédit ça me reste sur un petit
crédit sur 15 ans ça me ferait du bien
aux landaus et dieu dans tout ça dieu
dieu il est la 10e c1 il faut qu'on soit
honnête parce qu'on s'arrange il existe
surtout quand on a besoin de lui voilà
dieu est au mathis par tous les soirs et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
leonard youtube abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus